previously dans le cube de diamants très
bien et ben non mais pour avoir vu la
vidéo précédente pour comprendre celle
ci donc vous l'avez pas vu je vous
invite à aller la voir et si vous l'avez
déjà vu et ben c'est parti
et le coupable
et l'or l'or qui a profité que le groupe
était dans le noir pour prétexter une
peur du noir et c'est à ce moment là
qu'elle s'est emparé du cube de diamants
et puis la lumière s'est rallumée
ensuite ce cher anthony commence à avoir
une crise de panique et on a été obligé
de se concentrer sur lui ce qui lui a
laissé le temps de prendre le cube pour
le mettre dans mon sac oui mais si elle
avait vraiment voulu voler le caillou
leur avis directement dans son sac et
puis moi j'ai fait quand même pas mal
d'allers retours finalement se dire quoi
je suis coupable lors vous jean-jacques
c'est votre étourderie votre meilleur
défense quand vous est réapparu à la
porte juste ici votre braguette été
ouvertes avec un bout de t-shirts qui
sortait ce qui laisse fortement à
supposer que vous êtes passé par la case
toilettes et en plus quand la lumière
s'est rallumée le sac de l'or avait les
virements enflé pour pourquoi vous avez
fait semblant de ne pas me connaître
tout à l'heure un peu
non mais
non mais ça se j'aime bien me mentais
des vies
d'ailleurs jean jacques c'est pour mon
prénom
on va ré prénom c'est
esteban dallas note chez
n'existe pas comme prénom
et c'est vrai que justement encore jeu
halo la police oui c'est encore moi
écouter cette fois ci je suis à peu près
sûr de moi à vous et honte à moi c'est
parfait bah on vous attend alors
alors je m'appelle
lors qu'est ce que vous avez dans votre
sac là je restais ban de la noche de la
cabane à del fuego aller vérifier dans
le sac
excusez moi
mais c'est une copie je vais acheter à
la boutique
je savais vous allez dire ça je peux
prouver que vous êtes encore en train de
mentir passez moi non pas ce cube mais
celui que vous avez sorti de mon sac je
vous prouver que celui qui a été dans
mon sac est une copie c'est cela le vrai
qu il ya peu de casse tête il résiste et
j'imagine que les casse tête de la
boutique sont vraiment niveau débutant
alors que le cube de diamant je serais
incapable de l'ouvrir et voilà on
m'appelle le tueur de castets
sur riquet
chebbi un chat comme bruno oui mais
alors par contre
pour les larmes à l'impressionner ah ben
ça c'est très simple c'est ce cher
anthony qui a désactivé l'alarmé en
allant là-bas pendant que moi j'étais en
train de tourner le blog avec l'or qui
me filmer c'est d'ailleurs anthony qui a
provoqué la coupure de courant en
circulant vers le mur rien en appuyant
sur le bouton qui a là bas dans le fond
parce que oui mon cher je sais qu'elle
n'a pas agi seul je sais que vous êtes
complices vous avez beau être
sympathique et de leur très
professionnelle au demeurant la plupart
du temps il ya un moment vous n'aviez
plus vos gants alors jusqu'ici rien
d'anormal mais lorsque vous m'avez
ligoté j'ai pu apercevoir sur votre
poignet de la peinture de la peinture de
la même couleur que le mur du fond mur
du fond qui comporte deux informations
un panneau peinture fraîche et surtout
boîtier de la larme alarme dans le
j'imagine antonia lé code savez monsieur
bobards l'imagination ça vous mène loin
un oui j'ai le code de la larme parce
que je suis gardé amusé mais
oui oui bon je suis coupable d'accord et
laure aussi voilà tu te dis vous avouer
ça comme ça direct vous voilà oui je
j'ai joué j'ai perdu je sais pas voilà
c'est grave vous allez aller en taule un
prison tabac j'ai avoué faute avouée
faute pardonner non c'est pas comme ça
que ça fonctionne
tout sûr de votre coup la
séquence voici une enquête résolue en
moins de temps qu'il n'en faut pour vous
abonner quant à moi je m'appelle
toujours fabien olicard le tueur de
casse tête n'oubliez pas ça prenez soin
de vous à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
à
c'est bien aussi fabien olicard comme
prénom
fabien olicard talent anarchy
[Musique]